world's always changing in sometimes
characters are - hey folks it's time for
my monthly ish addressing of LGBTQ
issues in various pop culture media that
I partake in so that does mean we are
gonna be swapping out which I love which
I tend to do for these because I think
otherwise people tend to assume that I'm
not an actual part of the LGBTQ
community be TQ community when in fact I
am so reminder I have a fluid sense of
gender we can go with queer seems to be
the easiest and yes I do have more than
just the the cat I frames so let's talk
about retconning sexuality because this
is something that I saw come up a fair
bit in regards to other times that I've
talked about this especially would say
when I did kind of abate what ended up
by default being the first video and
kind of a series which was my
queerbaiting video and my video about
queerbaiting not a video where I was
cribbing anyways you know I talked about
in that video the whole issue of
creators writers directors Studios
whatever sort of pushing that a
character is in you know some version of
LGBTQ and then not delivering those
goods definitively in the end the work
itself and my issues with that and
something that Kat came up repeatedly in
the comments sometimes directly linked
to my mind mentioning the character of
Iceman who I am going to talk about in
specifics will get there but also in
general are people saying basically
expressing the sentiment I have no issue
with LGBTQ inclusion and representation
in my media what I don't understand is
why characters have to be changed
to be LGBTQ it's disrespectful to the
characters and it doesn't make sense or
you know some version of that was
something I saw a fair amount of and I
this is often the impetus for me to make
these videos which is that I found
myself having to basically because cuz a
lot of these things were said
respectfully I'm actually I've been
really happy with the with the comment
responses for the most parts of these
videos so these were said respectfully
and when I see a respectful inquiry like
that I'd like to reply and I found
myself kept replying the same way over
and over and over again and when I do
find myself doing that eventually oh I
just need to make a video so I don't
have to keep writing this out so the
argument like it's like I kind of summed
up is look you want LGBTQ characters
fine why are you co-opting existing
characters to be that representation why
aren't you introducing new characters
and there is a certain amount of
validity to that especially in regards
to the fact that there there is often a
hesitancy or a reluctance or a fear to
introduce new characters who are LGBTQ I
don't know if it's of a fear of
rejection I don't know if it's tied to
the fact that a lot of time surf ranches
really seem to resist introducing new
characters if they can help it in the
first place especially long-running
things like comic book continuity they
just want to keep going back to the same
characters over and over and over and
over again so you know it that that
could happen more absolutely but I
actually think there is a validity to
having a character not previously
identified as LGBTQ be revealed to be
that now before I get into explaining
why I think that actually can be a valid
choice
let me front-load this by saying it can
absolutely go wrong it can go horrible
it can result in something cringy
inauthentic that absolutely makes no
sense but I kind of just want to address
the base sort of argument that you can't
do that I think you can't I think
there's a valid reason to so I mentioned
Bobby Drake who
I did bring up in that queer they
queerbaiting video from a few months
back and I brought him up as an example
of a character where I thought that was
a solid choice and that that seemed to
be an issue I got a lot of pushback on
for people who otherwise agreed with
most of what I said now I do have to
admit to only having read bits and
pieces of his outing and what's gone on
since I haven't been reading it
exhaustively if it has gone off throws
or if a tip for time and got better I
seem to get I got conflicting reports
for people I have to own up to not
knowing front to back having followed
absolutely everything that's gone on
since since he was outed so that's my
maiya Copa there but I still will defend
that he was a solid candidate to do this
with and to explain why I need to
explain why I say it can be valid thing
because it is reality for many LGBTQ
people that we live a portion of our
lives sometimes a very significant
portion of our lives not allowing other
people to know that we are whatever we
are be it gay lesbian transgender
asexual gender-fluid genderqueer or
whatever it might be you know just to to
lay out a general timeline for myself
the first person who knew that I was
anything other than cisgender was I was
I was twenty that was in college and my
close family wouldn't find out for
probably another about five years from
there my close friends wouldn't start
finding out till another five or six
years from that I wouldn't be out
publicly until this year and that is
that
I I don't I don't think I've ever really
even been severely closeted but for me
it was a case of not sort of making it
overly public until I had a really good
handle on it because I knew there were
gonna be a ton of questions and I only
had so many answers so and there are
many reasons that um LGBTQ people don't
come out and sometimes it is fear
sometimes it's fear of rejection
sometimes it's honestly a period of
denial even of themselves some some
people some of us take a long time to
figure ourselves out much less even
after we do that being comfortable
allowing the world to know and you know
you can go all you want about like
everyone should be proud of who they are
yes they should be but sometimes what
you are and figuring out is damn
confusing and it takes a while so the
reality of presenting as cisgender
hetero
there is a validity in taking a
character who previously had been
portrayed as cisgender or heterosexual
and then revealing actually they're gay
there there's something else going on
with a gender identity there's whatever
I'll stick the same gay because that's
kind of the only way it's happening at
least so far as so far as I can tell so
there is actually a reason true-to-life
to why and before you go like well are
you saying that gay people like date the
opposite sex before they come out as gay
yeah sometimes sometimes they do
sometimes they do it as cover sometimes
they do it because they want to be
normal and they're honestly trying to
make it work and the reason I think that
Bobby Drake specifically was a good
candidate for this kind of change and
this is regardless of how well you do or
don't think of what the
reveal itself was handled or the
aftermath regardless of any of that I
think he was still a solid candidate and
here's why he is a character for who his
he was depicted as heterosexual but his
heterosexual relationships had never
been a primary defining feature of his
character or of his stories too to
explain that further I'll go for a point
of comparison quick who are the who are
the defining love interests of Batman
Superman spider-man and immediately you
can think Talia al Ghul or Catwoman Lois
Lane Mary Jane Gwen Stacy you know you'd
think Cyclops you immediately think Jean
Grey those you know those are characters
where a heterosexual relented and/or
sexual relationship is actually a huge
part of their character who's a
significant love interest of Iceman and
I'm not saying there weren't any but you
have to at least grant that only really
big fans of this character would have
been able to answer that question and
his romantic history had been a very
minor feature of his character he had it
had never been front and center again to
make it comparison within the x-men
unlike you know Kitty Pryde and Colossus
or Scott and Jean or Scott and and and
the white queen or you know whatever
else is going on this is some of those
some of those times Scott and Madeline
prior or gay
Scott is kind of a mess but Bobbie you
know he had some crushes that didn't go
anywhere he had some relationships that
were short-lived and that was sort of
the thing his relationships with women
were short not didn't seem to be
massively important to him and didn't
end well
so that kind of relationship pattern
bears more than a passing resemblance to
the relationship pattern of someone who
isn't straight but is trying to be for
whatever reason and again you know I'm
sure some people are
the logic well he's out as a mutant why
wouldn't you also be out as being gay
it's like the look first of all it's a
fictional he's a fictional universe so
you know it's hard to say how easier
hard it is to be out as a mutant but
beyond that you know the the two don't
equate because he's surrounded by other
mutants he's not surrounded by other
LGBTQ people so I don't think it's it's
that big of a leap to think that he is
cautious or uncomfortable about that
when he's totally comfortable with
something else that maybe society as a
whole is judging him for what his
friends aren't and I do think that kick
that if someone is going to be revealed
to be LGBTQ that is a pre-existing
character that a character like Bobby
is a good candidate and again I think
there is a validity to that now again
I'll say this and I said it before this
can absolutely go wrong and generally if
it does the way that it goes wrong is if
they fundamentally alter the way that
they're writing the character so if if
because being being gay or being
transgender or being whatever doesn't
[ __ ] doesn't change who you are as a
person so if a character is revealed to
be gay and then suddenly is treating
everybody around them massively
differently than they used to before and
suddenly their characterization is so
off from what it used to be you might as
well have just introduced a new
character yeah that's doing it wrong but
say someone like Rosa Diaz I'm Brooklyn
nine-nine five seasons in five seasons
of television I believe over a hundred
episodes at that point revealed to be
bisexual and it works spot-on because
the way in which it is revealed is
completely in keeping with who Rosa is
as a character and the way she treats
this situation and the people around her
in
selling them is completely true to that
character and it works and it can work
and it tracks with her it you look at
everything that's gone on with her and
you look at the scene where she comes
out which I encourage you to to look up
on YouTube it is up it's not like a
pirate scene like it's up as an official
clip released so check that out it's
real simple straightforward and again
absolutely true to the character so it
can be done badly it can be done well
but I do reject the premise of there's
no reason to take a straight cisgender
character and make them LGBTQ I think if
you're going to do that you need to
choose who you're gonna do it with
carefully and you need to handle it
carefully but I think that can be done
in a way that speaks to as I said the
truth of many LGBTQ experiences which is
a period of time where people don't know
and I think another one that's that's a
good example is willow in Buffy because
it was considered at least so far as as
I've been able to find it was considered
fairly early on that either
Xander or Willa would eventually be
revealed to be gay but early into the
show they didn't know which one of them
it would be so it was not dead certain
that willow was going to end up being
gay that was a decision made later so
that counts as a wreck on that counts is
changing it partway through but it still
works and it still flows because the
relationship that she had with Xander
was the kind of awkward first crush like
well this is a person I really like
doesn't that make me attracted to them
but then you actually find someone who
you are attracted to turns out they're
the same sex and you go oh this makes
sense now that's why things were weird
before and it flows and it's a narrative
that makes sense it is possible to have
a character previously portrayed only as
straight be revealed to be something
other than that
have it make sense it's really easy to
screw up the hole but yeah I just wanted
to to address the people who's who and I
don't think saying this hatefully but
I'm just hoping to bring another
perspective to anyone who just kind of
rejected that would reject the notion
but like I said there are plenty
characters you shouldn't do this with
anyone who you know have a having major
I heterosexual relationships has been a
defining feature of the character
probably a bad idea and that's not me
even saying that that sort of thing
never happens in reality because
honestly that does still happen in
reality there are people who are married
for years and honestly even love their
spouses but are still gay and are
married to someone of the opposite sex
and so that kind of stuff does still
happen but that that is a that's a kind
of narrative honestly if you're gonna
try and tackle that that's something you
shouldn't do as a retcon that is
something you should be planning for
that's part of the long game because as
difficult as it is to tackle people who
are in denial for a period tackling the
story of someone who is in denial while
being in a straight relationship for a
long long time that is a heavy topic and
not something to ever be taken lightly
so that that's the sort of thing that
I'm not saying shouldn't be done like
like it's on principle never do it but
like that is so heavy and you're gonna
engender so much animosity from people
that I I would recommend against it but
again to make the connection to reality
yeah that does happen too I do think
it's too gay that might be too much to
ask of of an audience though at least at
this point in time who knows things are
changing
times are changing and people change
which is how I started and that to me
says that that's a good place to end so
what are your thoughts on the idea of
retconning
sexual orientation or gender identity
the latter of which I don't know too
many examples of I imagine there's
probably some in anime I think there
were some references to that in the last
comments I enjoy animate but I don't
know it well enough especially the TV
shows to really be able to
into that area fandom but um in any case
whatever your thoughts on this are as
always i I see be respectful even if you
disagree with me
by all means disagree with me I actually
saw my favorite conversations that I've
been with people who disagree with me
but for who do so respectfully without
calling me names or using pejorative
terms so if you can keep it nice and
polite whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like and subscribe and
support me on patreon maybe and follow
me on Twitter I've got an email address
and sell t-shirts and all that stuff
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]